I saw um my mother what she said to you
I watched the show and that she said
keep breathing she's hilarious
Dory's tagline just keep swimming just
keep swimming
how would your tagline be just keep
breathing when I saw my god of course
she said just keep breathing she was a
little bummed that she didn't get a
voice in the film well you brought it up
I did for you so yes sure you've created
a monster
what would you see her as if her
character if there was something to
write her in what's the bossiest fish in
the ocean
what about Portia what fish receive you
what he felt I see her as like a
colorful angel fishers yes she would be
a she's the prettiest fish in the ocean
whatever that would be
she's really nice she's the angel the
prettiest angel fish you've ever seen
I'm Jennifer hey Marisa yes okay next
question
no not yet we're almost there getting
ready to move on and here we go my mom
my dad I have a family Ellen plays that
glue tank fish and finding Dory out this
Friday and she's still struggling with
her short-term memory Dory yes
Dory yes can you think of a time in your
life we're a little short term memory
loss may to come in handy oh okay like
maybe like an advancing ball know that
you'd like to forget oh sure there's
there's plenty I was shooting my HBO
special in New York and I was taking
questions from the audience and someone
stood up and I said yes sir right there
and she goes I'm a ma'am and I'm so
embarrassed and I'm like and then she
ends up telling me the story of me
coming out she saved her life she starts
crying and it was this beautiful moment
so you embrace your embarrassing moment
you have to you have to embrace all the
moments in life because they all add to
something that makes you a better person
because there's one thing about for me
where I'm presenting it
I got Awards on de jure and what
happened I was wondering what that was I
had it all my life covered with
something yeah like I was presenting
something else listen you you I'm gonna
say brought it up and I that's the
surprise now well okay I'm not gay then
you can so you have that usual all right
good I can use a little short term
memory loss right now you don't I mean
guys I I will say this I don't think
I've ever laughed so hard in an
interview before I mean it was so much
like people behind the camera in front
of the cabin we were all cracking up